[Music]
[Applause]
so
happy birthday
[ __ ]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
why
oh
[Music]
um
oh
well
oh
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
uh
foreign
foreign
oh
well it took all day but i did it i
built a spear gun from scratch
now last night i went and added a little
bit of rubber and that gives me just a
little bit of tension
so that i can wrap the string around the
end of the shaft and keep it pinned to
the spear gun
you can see like that it just wraps
around the end of the spear keeps it
strapped to the gun
i like that
now we're gonna see if we can go get a
fish with it
so
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
foreign
so
so
oh
so
that was really cool that was better
snorkeling than i expected
this is a nine-nine type of surgeon fish
you can see they call them surgeonfish
because they have these little sharp
scalpels on their tails
you gotta cut those off
[Music]
we're back at the house and we're gonna
cook up those fish that i shot
[Music]
what do you want jake little tiny fish
all right it's yours but this one ah
there you go little kool-aid
all right we got this little nine-nine
here i like nine eyes it tastes a lot
like cole it was the first fish i ever
shot in it in hawaii was a 99
these little fried fish the tails are
also really good
well that was some good food and i hope
you guys enjoyed this video if you want
to see more build projects from the
outdoor boys youtube channel check out
our build projects video and if you want
to see this travel adventure check out
our travel adventure playlist and check
out our 10-day kawaii fishing adventure
and i'll put a link to that video in the
video description below as well thanks
for watching and don't forget to click
subscribe we put out new videos every
saturday morning okay
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]